can you uh speak to the
um
the efforts to increase diversity in
universities which I think is embodied
in this uh die effort of diversity
inclusion and Equity programs where do
they go right where did do they go wrong
okay let me tell you first of all this
may surprise a lot of people
I am opposed to affirmative action
um and I think that
um what it does is it
labels people by their race
by their religion and by their national
origin
precisely what we don't want people to
do is we pigeonholed in those categories
the reason that affirmative action has
become the way that universities decide
on who gets admitted
is because historically people in what's
called marginalized groups
blacks gays Hispanics
have been discriminated against in the
admissions process
now
what I have suggested
is that instead of affirmative action
and by the way here's a prediction the
Supreme Court is going to abolish
affirmative action is a case penis
Harvin case
um it's the there's a there are two
cases joined together one of a public
university and one of a private
university the private university is
Harvard
I predict that the Supreme Court will
vote six to three to abolish affirmative
action
it is on its face
it is a violation of equal protection of
the law
some groups are favored because of race
or ethnicity it is a classic violation
of equal protection clause
when affirmative action was approved
this deciding vote was just the Sandra
Day O'Connor she wrote a very famous
opinion in which she said
I am hesitate to vote to up to keep up
there to affirm the notion of
affirmative action because it's such an
obvious violation of equal protection
but we have an urgent problem in the
society we are not educating our um
members of racial ethnic minorities
and we have to try to get them into
colleges
um so I'm I think it should be approved
for 25 years
um and um it will uh it should be it
should in 25 years they should have
performed its role well it hasn't and
the 25 years is coming up I think it's
three or four years left
the Supreme Court is going to abolish it
you can take my word for them
because it's such an obvious violation
of equal protection
why do why does affirmative action come
into play
because the secondary in elementary
schools are so bad
public secondary in elementary schools
are so bad
why are they so bad partly because of
the control of the teachers union
has Randy Weingarten runs the public
school system in the United States
and what I have suggested
is that
the effort should be
to uh this is an emergency it's a
national emergency
to improve
the quality of Elementary and secondary
education
and one way to do it is to hire teachers
who are fabulous teachers rather than
necessarily members of the Union
I have come to oppose
public workers unions
I am a very strong supporter of reunions
in the private sector
why do I think there's such a difference
between unions in the public sector and
the private sector
in the private sector management is
arguing
bargaining with its own money and with
the money of shareholders
in the public sector there's only one
side
there is the teachers union and then
there's a school committee that is
dealing with the taxpayers money not
their room and so it's a very skewed
power battles so
as supportive as I am of private sector
unions I am in a opposition of Public
Safety unions they're very destructive
and I think without the teachers union
teachers who are really skilled will be
able to get jobs they would not have to
worry about the seniority of teachers
who long since have given up really
creative
teaching
and we have to improve the public
educational system
um I had um in my late wife and I
um uh had a classmate of we have a son
who's Now 44 who went to the public
schools in Cambridge
he has a friend
first name Eugene
who was black kid from Roxbury whose
mother understood that the schools in
Roxbury were terrible the schools in
Cambridge were pretty good
he lived in our house
Monday to Friday and he went to school
with Isaac in the Cambridge Public
Schools
elsewhere and I would show up the school
committee meetings when there was
bargaining between the teachers union
and the school committee
um that teaches you in objected to our
being there
we argued we're taxpayers we have a a
kid in the school and we have his best
friend lives with us
and goes to school with them
uh we have a real interest
and um the school committee
walked out of the borrowing session the
city council then reconsidered his vote
and they voted that we that citizens
taxpayers parents of kids in the school
could not show up
to these negotiation sessions
I thought that was absolutely outrageous
but I understood why because these
contracts are crazy
no sane municipality
should enter into some of these
contracts
um and um so I am
I have become an opponent of the
national Teachers Association the
Cambridge teaching a lot Cambridge
Teachers Association I don't think there
should be unions for public employees
because there's no real bargaining going
on
and um I think that the public school
system will never be improved as long as
the the the teachers are unionized
so that to you as at the core of the
problem that results in uh the kind of
inequality of opportunity that
affirmative action is designed to
resolve so if you if the educational
system in the Elementary and high school
levels is improved we wouldn't need
affirmative action these kids would get
good educations
so from all backgrounds
poor kids in the United States will get
good education correct if uh
uh public unions are abolished correct
yeah but do you more incidentally the
Postal Service would probably work
better too
that's a whole other conversation but do
you at the core of the problem of the
inequality in in universities
that diversity inclusion and Equity
programs are trying to solve is the
public education system of secondary
education yes correct Elementary and
second Elementary and secondary
education well then is there use what is
the benefit what is the drawback of uh
d-i-e diversity inclusion and Equity
programs at universities that Harvard
it's an affirmative action basically and
what it does is it allows the system of
Elementary and secondary education to be
bad because they could say oh we got our
kids into Harvard yes but you haven't
educated them
and it covers up the wound
and I think we will never improve as
long as we're able to cover up the wound
and as I said affirmative action is
going to be abolished by the Supreme
Court
it's a clear violation of equal
protection is what central Day O'Connor
understood but ignored
intentionally but as an experiment
uh and um I believe it's going to be
abolished and that's going to have
that's going to force
the Elementary and high schools to get
serious